all right time for the movie
retrospective trying to Busan yeah not
going too far back this when this came
out in 2016 but we you know usually we
do older movies but hobby classic that
we wanted to do this one because nuclear
love this movie so much and it really is
an instant classic yeah this is a new
classic now having lived in Korea for a
year you know this this one I really
like this one because you know I knew
the setting and I knew the culture and
it's called trying to Busan Busan uh the
city it's a city in Korea might be we
called it Pusan with a P the P and B are
kind of interchangeable in Korean you
know anyone in that yeah Busan sometimes
it's actually spelled Pusan on the maps
but anyway I hear KATUSA is call it
Busan and I was at Pier is it being
there like that same thing yeah this new
therapy Nora be in the in their written
language being either it could be there
it could be either yeah but a pretty
cool movie because it shows the terrain
everything is a [ __ ] either a valley
or a mountain in Korea and in every one
of those valleys is uh something like
you're like trains you know train tracks
rice paddies or towns and factories and
there's nothing in the mountains that's
weird but you can see it yeah I see it
in the movie yeah I climbed over every
one of those [ __ ] miles carrying a
damn m60 boy ran hard work but what I
like about this movie okay the town of
this movie it's you can tell that the
director I'm sure you're gonna talk
about it uh what's his name uh Yong
Seungho yeah okay
I have noticed in Korean movies there's
another cream of area like called
Musa or mousse of the warrior yeah it's
kind of a medieval flick about a bunch
of Korean soldiers back in medieval
times get lost in China and they get
it's kind of like their version of
Saving Private Ryan all kinds of bad
[ __ ] happens but Korea there's not
really because there's mandatory service
in Korea most Korean men's have some
kind of a military background and
[ __ ] Korean service is tough you know
they got [ __ ] tough airborne troops
tough hustle force
is they got tough Marines so you know
they were a military dictatorship for a
long time you know I mean fighting the
North or resisting the north so what
when it comes to Indies action movies
there's not an ounce of soy in them
there's it is it it's very different
situation than say Japan they have a
little it looks like a Japanese movie
but you can tell that it was made by
guys that have some grit to him and
there's a lot of kind of like warrior
virtue built into it enter into Korean
action movies and all that plays out in
this in this particular movie there's a
lot of male archetypes showing the
strengths and weaknesses of them yeah
and in this flick so it's not just a
superficial zombie flick it's a morality
tale to which that's really why I think
this is an important movie aside from
that it's just [ __ ] awesome yeah it's
like not only that like yes it does have
like social commentary I guess you would
call it it does have like you know
hero's journey of all the different
characters and stuff but it's also just
a really really fun action movie I mean
it's like super fast paced it's like you
know it's it has fast zombies just kind
of like 28 days later yeah there yeah it
comes out the zombies for some how is a
virus that comes out of a Korean biotech
company yeah one of the one of the one
of the guys is a hedge funds manager who
has something to do with that company -
yeah he's the main character yeah his
his character's name is siiiick woo and
he is actually he works for a company
that I don't think they actually caused
the outbreak but they had something to
do with like funding it or something
like that so they're kind of like sort
of responds yeah and I like the fact
that they really didn't explain what had
happened he just shows a deer getting
hit by a car deer dying and a deer
getting out there walking up which is
the great open air whatever whatever
whatever it happened has already you
know the the outbreak has already
happened I guess you kind of let you
know it's coming from a Korean biotech
company maybe it's some kind of
bioweapon that got out or yeah the
experiment of so it's never explained
and I like the fact that they didn't
explain it yeah because it
not really matter I mean really what
matters is the outcome like the journey
and the outcome we let you wander and
for all we know maybe there's a prequel
or another experience a prequel know
pretty well we got to see it it's called
it's in actually might still be on
Netflix this is on Netflix too and it is
also on shudder so you know there's a
couple places you can see it there is
actually a prequel is animated and it's
called soul station okay and it came out
only a few months before a few months
after this action ok
and I believe it's still on Netflix I
just haven't got around to see yeah it
might be on Netflix or shudder I know
I've seen it but yeah so it's a prequel
to this so I'm assuming that it explains
and if any of you all have seen it I'm
assuming that it explains like maybe
where are they yeah Brett came from you
could tell that you could tell that this
director has seen not a living dead yeah
there's a lot of Night of the Living
Dead callbacks that were there watching
television and news in which is that's a
great way of giving the story more scope
that when you got the characters
watching TV yeah that worked you can
also tell that you could also tell that
you know they had seen the other ones
like was it for 28 days later yeah yeah
and you could sell that Walking Dead was
an influence to you can see that Walking
Dead was a big influence it's kind of
like I like this because I've seen this
movie called snowpiercer with zombies
it's also kind of like World War Z
except good because that made was not
good all right what was good but the
movie was not a lot of people shed on
World War Z it wasn't that bad I enjoyed
it wasn't I are loaded I just compared
to the book it just really wasn't that
good okay I didn't read the book oh yeah
I thought it was a decent movie that's
all i'ma say about it it was a decent
movie had a big scope yeah movie yeah I
don't think I spent a whole lot of time
on characters I don't remember any of
them care that was the issue that I had
yeah I remember any damn character film
it in in a way that's what makes this
movie so compelling it's driven by
character it's very character driven but
like I said it's not not in like a
boring Otaki scenes kind of well they
the way that they directed it it's kind
of like you just get like a few scenes
with each character because it's kind of
an ensemble cast yeah but you get a
sense of them like immediately and you
start caring about them and because show
don't tell movie it definitely is
alright then it's got the three main
characters who are very different from
one another kind of drive this story
there are female characters also in this
story that drive it but the focus is on
kind of like a hedge fund manager who
has everything going for him except he's
not a good family man yeah and he's not
really a hero then you got another guy
that's kind of like a [ __ ] burly
working-class guy who's a new father and
he's got his pregnant wife and he's just
a brawler all right yeah but he doesn't
have it he's not a [ __ ] real rich guy
he's like a construction worker type guy
yeah and he's he's made he's made his
living with his hands and you know he's
kind of like he's he's actually kind of
a Sylvester Stallone character of this
movie I would say he's a lot like a
character a young Stallone will play
yeah and then the other one is uh where
they call him captain
we found out that he had a Chilean
nickname well I just died in the movie I
don't know if that's in the movie or not
in business what I was looking for the
photos like to put in the video the name
of the photo of his character was
captain that's not what his name was and
that's what I'm gonna call him captain
business is this [ __ ] up in the train
in his 60s it's a [ __ ] he's a he's a
big businessman right yeah but he suck
at highly manipulative and he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's really only just trying
to save himself yeah he's trying to save
his own and he I don't know if I should
spoil it in case you guys have a scene
trying to Busan but this dude lives up
this dude lives up to the [ __ ] title
of a different kind of [ __ ] yes but
what you know it when you see it you
know this kind of guy when you see it
and in the end his true nature is
revealed and in his final moments you
find out what this what drives this kind
of dude yeah they will do anything to
start to stay alive and who thinks he's
better than everybody else
yeah it's like he is seriously he's a
good he's a great villain so obviously
I'm gonna fight zombies the villain but
he is like a great villain in this
because he is just like so easy to hate
he's just a douche anything is
realist and it's not real under
realization it's not realistic all the
acting is very good in this movie it's
all very good acting and I could feel
the Korean s of all these characters cuz
living in Korea I knew people I knew
people like this you run to them in run
into them in a train or you'd serve and
serve with them in the army that could -
so serve them was when you deal with you
know ROK army soldiers because though
they're in here - they're not I didn't
see any KATUSAs but there's a lot of ROK
army guys in it yeah and that's how they
are yeah yeah I have to say - that it's
like Korea kills it with these type of
movies maybe you didn't see um I saw the
devil did you no I didn't see a whole
[ __ ] I'm gonna see it does and I was
talking about it with somebody on you on
the YouTube in the comments I was like
that that is for real one of the best
movies of any genre that I have ever
seen ever yeah I mean and I'm telling
you the reason why is because the
cultural situation I like the Japanese
and you know I like Japanese products
and the thing is is that the upbringing
in Japan and the upbringing in China by
America's standards is for the good for
the guys is kind of milk toasty but not
in Korea it shows it there a little milk
toasty but not but they for did they're
forced to be soldiers a lot of them at a
early age you know Korea although it is
an advanced country today went during
the time I was there was still a
developing nation and it was tough so
allows guys are still around yeah this
is before kpop we're wearing makeup and
all that [ __ ] that didn't but most of
the guys who were who were running
around Korea right now are not of that
generation yeah you know I mean they're
my generation too so they're they're
very they're tough yeah especially for
especially for that part of the world
because you know they tend to pamper man
you know in in that parlor we're lucky
they don't know it but the sons are just
kind of like raised as little princes
and [ __ ] yeah the girls are doing all
the hard work really yeah yeah they're
like the boy to go to college and [ __ ]
so he's you know grown service burn in
his mouth yeah that's that's kind of Dan
that is actually discussed in this movie
because there's some of that has always
gone on even in Korea yeah the Korean
rich boy is gonna come up a little
different of course than a Korean
working-class guy and that's kind of
what they show in a movie although
everything about it I mean okay so I
mean at the center of the movie the
hedge fund manager SIOC woo like he's
kind of like the main character yeah and
his whole central conflict is like he
said he's you know a high up businessman
he's divorced from his wife so he's
presumably moved back in with his mother
and he has a daughter named Suwon yeah
and he's not like the greatest dad like
he he's trying to like just like by her
love but he doesn't really you know he's
at the beginning like he missed her
singing recital and she messed up
because he wasn't there and she was
crying and he's kind of a superficial
yuppie he's not he's not into that [ __ ]
and he brings her like a Nintendo Wii
even though he already had one and he
had actually given it to her like you
know prior and he had forgotten all
about it
so he brings her another one for a
birthday so the whole thing that sets
the thing in motion is that for her
birthday she wants to go see her mom and
it was on could they're in Seoul and so
he doesn't want to take her and it's
like this big deal but then finally he
feels bad about missing her thing and
everything so he's like okay fine I will
take you on the train and so they get on
the train and the cool thing about it is
that you know you're with these people
on the train so at first they don't
really know what's going on because like
some of them like have phones and they
have the news but it's like when the
news is on you can tell that they're
trying to like keep everyone calm you
know what I mean it's a riot so there's
no there's a riot or there's like you
know they're just saying things like
that no panic and all the old ladies are
like oh look at them they're so food
they're so rude and ill-behaved yeah we
never used to put up with that kind of
yes you know back then they was then re
educated yeah and the main guy and I get
their names all confused cuz they
actually don't use their names much of
the movie much they don't really know
each other yeah and then in Korea and
Korean the names are backwards the last
name comes first and the way that yeah
and they say it backwards and then
that's the the subtitles are the other
way around so you're like he didn't say
that well yeah senator I'm talking about
anyway his character flaw is a he he's
selfish she won't yeah
he he won't sacrifice anything for
anybody else but she's not his family
yeah he just won't sacrifice anything
and I mean his daughter like calls him
out on that pretty much she's like
that's why mom left right it's probably
true right see he's yelling at her
daughter because she gives like an old
lady her seat yeah and then he's like
you know oh you shouldn't do that you
know you should just look out for
yourself and all the other kind of stuff
and [ __ ] and then she just tells him
that he's off and then the other big the
other big characters exactly the
opposite the working-class guy he's
ready to sacrifice everything for his
family he's yeah you know and it goes
they just he's the best he's actually
the best character I'd like to see more
more movies with him in it in there he's
in a bunch of movies I've seen I've seen
a bunch of other count ahead to me he
had the same charisma as like a semester
Stallone tan character Arab actor like a
samosa stallone type actor it's like
somebody put in an action movie
he's like the cool thing about his
character like I said him and his wife
um he's like he doesn't need to learn he
is good-hearted from the beginning yeah
it's just natural to him and it's you
know so it comes naturally to him
whereas you know uh siamo is more like
you know this tragedy like kind of makes
him learn yeah you know student become
that way that you have to be more like
that guy yeah you know anyway you know
have the man has to [ __ ] come
face-to-face with sacrifice
self-sacrifice yeah yes is what whatever
what it is to be a family man yeah and
not just saving families but saving
other people how the Train because it
gets to a point where because like I
said as the cuz the Train it's a bullet
train and it's I think it's some from
Seoul to Busan I think I read that it
was like 280 miles or something like
that so they're on this train and as I
said they're going and they're not
entirely sure what's going on so it's
like when they stop at this one station
and there's like there's nobody there
and it's like super weird said they get
off and they you know cuz the driver is
like well we're not really sure what's
going on we're not getting like any
feedback from like and if the station's
up ahead so it's like when they stop at
this one and it seems deserted and so
they're gonna go try to get on another
train but then it turns out that the
whole [ __ ] thing is yeah full of
zombies another cool character in this
movie is the damn train that is the
train engineer yeah he doesn't have a
whole lot of love
green time yeah but he's if you've ever
seen if you've you ever seen dr.
Strangelove he kind of reminds me of
slim pickings in duck yeah the captain
of the b-52 that by hell or high water
is gonna drop that atomic bomb on one of
these damn targets and he's the guy in
he leads the crew to just go above and
beyond you know he's got all the Soviet
Air Force and all the American Air Force
trying to stop this this this bomber
that's been accidentally ordered to drop
his atomic bombs and this guy's just
making it through like you know through
huge odds you know and he still makes it
that's the way this this train this
train is gonna is gonna get to Busan
yeah because he has taken personal
responsibility for all the people on a
train you know what I mean and then you
also have we forgot to mention the
homeless guy because that's what I mean
it's like he looks kind of like you know
he's kind of dirty and grubby and stuff
like that so you know people look at him
as Gantz and is like he's the first one
that knows this something's wrong yeah
because he gets on the train singles
they're all dead they're all dead yeah
you know but nobody listens to him
because they said it looks like a bomb
yeah now treat him like [ __ ] and they
all treat him like [ __ ] okay and he
proves his worth you know what I mean
that he was a good person you know I
just that's right it's the the thing
about it is like the character
development and this is so good and like
I said they don't spend a huge amount of
time on it because it's an ensemble cast
you have those four main guys you have
like the whole a whole subplot with like
a whole baseball team and like yeah this
girl that's their cheerleader then
that's you know that one of them is you
know kind of going out with yeah they
gotta he's embarrassed that he's got a
girlfriend which is that's just a toilet
that's a totally Korean thing where the
boys have to appear to be a virgin until
they're married that's some weird [ __ ]
yeah yeah then they have the two old
ladies that are sisters yeah and then
there's like a you know a bunch of other
layer there's a bunch of there's a bunch
of female armed values being shown in
the movie two about sisterhood and you
know I mean and kind of sticking
together this is about you know the main
thing I mean the main theme of the movie
is selflessness yeah
you know what I mean um and and I think
the cheerleader girl was due important
doing acts of bravery yeah because
everybody kind of said I mean other than
that it's pretty much everybody yeah
captain busy and some of the other
[ __ ] like in the first-class
carriage yeah they didn't want to let
like anybody because well it's strange
it's typical [ __ ] because captain
business also had a bunch of suck asses
yeah coming up on because they want to
live - that's right listen to captain
business yeah you'll see so that was
like a whole and like I said you know
yeah there's a lot of horror movies
where it's like you know in a confined
space and there's like all this bad [ __ ]
happening but the reason there's a lot
of horror movies like that is because
it's really effective yeah because this
train is like kind of flying through
that you know they don't know they can't
stop anywhere because like the you know
the the other stations are overrun so
they're trying to get through to Busan
because somebody somewhere heard that
maybe the military was there and maybe
it would be okay it would be safe from
Busan but you know somebody like this
one girl like stumbles on the train and
once she starts biting people because
like I said these are fast-moving
zombies so each carriage is getting
slowly like taken over by the zombies
and so they're all like kind of like
running toward the first-class carriage
like to get away from the zombies as the
zombies like are catching up to them
like in the back yeah edges you know I
mean there's just a bunch of a bunch of
stuff breaks out a bunch of commentary
about Korean society like captain
business in order to save himself
actually starts taking charge of the of
most of the damn trade yeah and then
there's a bunch of social commentary
that your average Korean is so class
oriented that they fall right in line
listening to captain business yeah and
then a bunch of lieutenants start you
know basically backing captain business
that ought to preserve themselves yeah
because Korea is but is a male-dominated
societies very class structured it's
very top-down so it's a class-based
society and that and that movie kind of
pokes fun at it at that yeah because
this is definitely an anti-authoritarian
sort of movie because the movie comes
out and says these dumbass robots follow
this guy yeah you know now some of the
smart characters didn't go with the pack
yeah like--on I see what
that's what I mean all the good guys
kind of like ended up going against that
guy you know what I mean because and in
in a way like all the people that went
along with captain business I didn't
they do end up getting like punished for
that ya know what I mean
yeah blame the moral of that story was
as you know is that just blindly
following a leader because because he's
successful doesn't necessarily mean he's
out for your well-being that did clearly
he didn't give a [ __ ] he just want I
mean he just wanted like people backing
him up so he could like lock everybody
else out yes they not help that yeah and
you know what I mean so and he was
directly responsible for a bunch of
other people he hadn't killed just
because of his ass you're like why is
this guy such an [ __ ] in the very end
you find out who he truly is although I
still didn't feel bad for him no that
was like well that doesn't excuse it
right but that was that was the force
that was driving him yeah he had regrets
it was understandable right yeah but I
still didn't like feel bad for him what
the story is saying is is that he that
he was so spiritually immature that he
could never do an act of selflessness
yeah because he was infantile yeah okay
that's actually yeah that's anyway
maturity is about saying [ __ ] I'm
ready to go out for I'm ready to die
yeah for these people you know and that
that's what they were taught and that's
what they were that's what was lauded
promise I mean and they were pretty
blatant about it too he's like I said I
mean the whole you know the whole main
plot was like you know hedge fund
manager and his daughter sue on and I
mean she basically says straight up to
his face that his selfishness was why
his wife left court Korea is a Christian
country that that's kind of its official
religion all right but it also has a lot
of Buddhist influence and there's a lot
of buit Buddhist influence in this ya
story so that you know you the two could
actually kind of merge because Buddhism
Buddhism is more of a philosophy than it
is a religion you know yeah actually I
would say Buddhism is a religion
Buddhism is a philosophy that became a
religion yeah you know
because I think the people are really
into Buddhism know that the tails and
the tails inside Buddhism are examples
yeah they're not of actually
historically accurate you know yes not
stuff that actually happened it's
examples but yeah I mean you can
definitely tell that the whole point of
this movie was that you know helping
others is like you know it's or even
even up to sacrificing yourself with
others is kind of like the highest
virtue yeah we're all gonna die anyway
yes--we Buddhism would look cool and a
lot of people did because it's like
zombie apocalypse well I'm gonna die
anyway the human lifespan isn't very
long yeah so you know it means you have
to be ready and willing to give up your
life for certain things that are greater
than you yeah that's the that's the
moral behind it yeah and I was gonna say
too that this is one of the only horror
movies I've ever seen where I actually
kind of cried at the end is good it was
really sad it was like a really sad and
like a really like emotionally affecting
ending and the only reason that it that
it had that effect was because you gave
a [ __ ] about the characters yeah like
when a character you like died it was
upsetting like you know I mean like a
lot of movies don't have that that you
could make a whole trilogy in movies
like these I heard that they might make
a sequel like I hope so I think God be
the same director in the same writers
man yeah I'd be the same type of script
I heard that um James Wan was maybe
gonna do an english-language version but
I was like I don't really care about
that and I don't like when they do like
American remakes of Asian films not
necessarily some of them are going
obvious well that's just a way of
picking up some extra bucks on it [ __ ]
that's already done and ready to spin it
a little bit differently I'd like to see
the same director go ahead and and go
one step further what happened to Busan
yeah once I got Busan what happened yes
because it was never really resolved
it's a get to Busan yeah
what happens then you know yeah you know
cuz is now yeah that wasn't over yeah
yeah because you don't know you know I'm
you know I don't I don't necessarily
want to spoil the end because this movie
is not become a worldwide pandemic I'm
sure if I'm right it seemed like it was
very widespread I mean it's at least
throughout Korea us
soldiers and coming and going from that
country all day long see that means that
disease was spread right to the United
States vision because it's like 28 days
later disease it spreads super fast like
as soon as somebody has bitten like only
minutes later they start like contorting
and yeah and it doesn't sit and and well
they you get if you get bitten you die
in turn yeah but that that deer wasn't
infected got hit and turned so I think
it might be kind of like Walking Dead
everybody has it and when they die and
then when they died they turn and maybe
they may be getting bitten is enough to
kill you pretty quickly they might be
carrying some kind of a you know pretty
contagious or you know highly yeah
highly poisonous [ __ ] bacterial virus
or something you know I mean because I
don't know because I don't think that
deer was a zombie was it when it got
well I don't know because he just said I
mean the guy was just coming back and he
just like hit it with the car yeah it
was a zombie I think it was a zombie and
then it got hit and it got back up
anyway I think yeah but yeah so like I
said I've heard that they're making a
sequel I think it's called bandeau or
bond over Smith and that's one no no
James Wan was doing a version of this
but in English language but I don't know
if that fell through or not because
they've been talking about that for a
couple years now as I said there was a
prequel to this which is animated called
soul station which I haven't got around
to seeing yet cuz you know probably need
to see that so they might have like look
they might have gone into that issue
yeah um but again this movie actually
for a while I think it's set like a lot
of Records it's like the
highest-grossing movie in like several
Asian countries in this Malaysia oh they
don't make another one and so yeah stuff
like that so it made like a you know a
93 million dollars something like that
which is like it's a big deal for for a
Korean movie for a Korean movie yeah
yeah and I mean the reviews of this
pretty much everybody I know that has
seen this movie loves this vector how
can you not love this place movie I mean
Rotten Tomatoes 95% yeah you know what I
mean it's got like usually and and
rightfully so because like I said not
only this have great acting great
characters that you really get invest in
you actually care when something bad
happens to them you know the ending of
it is like really affecting and really
upsetting but it's also like just a fun
like it just it never stops I mean
because this train is going and it's
like everybody's turning into zombies
like there's waves of zombies there's
like zombies hanging onto the back of a
train like being dragged it's [ __ ] like
that even but it's great and the movie
did the movie was you could tell that it
was influenced a lot by the you know the
American zombie movies that the movie
the movie didn't sell out it's still a
Korean movie yeah there's still a lot of
Korean sensibilities and a bunch of
Korean culture in there but the way it's
shot is shot like a really good western
movie yeah the good Korean or a really
good Hollywood type movie and actually
not one of these new Tet poll Hollywood
movies
it's actually shot kind of like a really
cool independent film movie yeah that's
what I think is shot like almost kind of
retro but you know how some of the retro
stuff is so good now you know I mean
it's almost because the storytelling
them back in the night he was kind of
coherent you know yeah now it's all over
the place this shit's very coherent yeah
like I said it's very straightforward
it's very straightforward story it's
very simple like I said it's just it's
basically just Sambi son a train and the
train just keeps moving and the zombies
just you know they just keep building up
building up and the marriages and like
that people are just basically trying to
get away from them you said there might
be it might be a sequel yeah any any
word on it no I don't know I'm just
saying they've been talking about the
you know the same director said that
he's been working on a sequel good so
we'll see it wouldn't shock me if there
was one because like I said this was a
massively successful is easily one of
the if not Davos again you're in South
Korea maybe you'd be kicking yourself in
the nuts if he didn't make mm well yeah
means [ __ ] they make sequels too like
[ __ ] that there wasn't even that's been
years so that means they're not rushing
it yeah that's a good sign
well so like this came out in 2016 I
think it first premiered at the Cannes
Festival and then it had a theatrical
run I don't think it had a theatrical
run year to a theatrical run all over
Asia and made a lot of money there might
have had a brief theatrical run here so
maybe like probably like a four-year
break in between the two that's they'd
be perfect amount of time yeah that's
probably got it takes a couple years to
make the movie but yeah so I mean this
is very easy to find like I said it's
still on Netflix as I think Seoul
station is on there as well
shudder just added it a couple months
ago too so if you have shudder or not
Netflix you can watch it on there too
and I think Amazon Prime [ __ ] like that
but like I said you know that believe
the hype because a lot of people have
like said about
should even Edgar Wright that guy that
made Shaun of the Dead he was just like
this is a best zombie movie I've ever
seen or like one of the best Tommy
movies ever seen and it really is I mean
he understands the genre yeah it's like
easily top 10 top 5 even zombie movies
because there's a lot of shitty ones out
there yeah you know seriously cuz so
much of its been no that's no that's oh
man this movies got sold yeah but this
one is like super great and it's all
just down to the characters and the
writing and the writing the pace of it
it's just like really really awesome and
it's like oh some of the gags like a
guys are really really really good like
yeah the soggy carpet yeah there's a
whole carpet of damn zombies all trying
to climb on the back zombie wave
breaking through the glass yeah that was
a good one just hilarious is like you
know when they're coming through the
carrots they're all like so excited
they're trying to get there try to climb
over top of each other so it's just like
these two just like [ __ ] waves yeah
zombies like people crawling over and
preparing yeah there's no real way to
lock the damn doors in the train cars so
you can't see had to hold the train
doors closed there's a side door
bunch of problems with that uh yeah so
it's just like this whole row this whole
series of problems that they're trying
to figure out like you know kind of on
the fly and only and then once you lock
yourself into a train bathroom full of
zombies how the hell do you get out yeah
because there's just but there's no way
to get out because there's like hundreds
that are available on this train and
like they're slowly turning into zombies
like by one but yeah but seriously if
you have not seen this movie see this
movie it's [ __ ] amazing yeah um you
know which you know because we don't
usually do once this nailin
retrospective but we just made an
exception this time around just because
some of them use someone who does
require use kind of a scene yeah and
this is just because we love you so much
so seriously good a Netflix good a
shudder and check it out you will love
it I promise we will see you next time
bye